VICTORY OVER THE OILERS I I
STICK.
PULJUJARVI CAN'T CLEAR OFF OF
SLATER KOEKKOEK FIRES RIGHT ON,.
KNOCKED OFF THE STICK OF  COMES
MATTHEWS TAKES IT UP TO THE IGHT
LINE, PLAYS IT INTO THE HOLL, MN
AS BUNTING IS INVEGAS,
BIG REBOUND!
MIKE SMITH HAS TO MAKEHE FORWAR
CACA THE LEAFS BACK IN THE OUT.
YAMAMOTO TOOK THOSE EXTRA TWO
STEPS.
IF YOU WATCH MORGAN RIELLY FOR
TORONTO.
RIELLY, CENTRES, BUNTING UNABLE
.
>> Craig: THE ONE THING YOU DO.
SMART CHOICE, ALLOWING THE
GOALTENDER TO MIKHEYEV, AND
>> Craig: FOR NYLANDER, AGAIN,
SQUARE TOAVE NOT BEEN BUSYIN.
GOT BUMPED THERE BY HOLL. PLAYE
CHANCE GOES TO EDMONTON
SHORTHANDED.
>> Craig
ALLOWED A POWER PLAY IN FOUR
STRAIGHT AND IT SEEMS WHEN ONE
BUT NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
A TRIGGER GO.
COME ON, BOYS
>>
RIELLY SENDS IT IN.
BUBU TO THE LEAF
LINE.
UP AHEAD OF DIVING THE BOARDS T
ENDED UP FIELDING HIMSELF N NOW
NYNY
TORONTO.
8-7 OILERS IN THE SECOND. BY AU
LEAD FEED TO HAVE
OF THE NET.
KEITH TRYING TO CLEAR IT AHEADY
NYLANDER TO GET INTO A SITUATION
WHERE HE COULD TIP IT B OILERS
GOING TO CLEAR THE ZONE.
KOEKKOEK UNABLE TO GET IT.
LOOK AT THE
>> Craig: FOR THE OILERS AFT GO
.
THERE'S A SHOT AND CAMPBELL IS
GOING TOHARD.
LEON DRAISAITL, BOUCHARD, NOT IN
THE WHEEL  REACTION BY TAVARES,
PRESSURE.
DON'T GIVE A